I do like being out of house I got I got
a family so it's always nice to leave
and that sounded worse than it is but I
you know I got some old kids and it's
funny when your kids start doing [ __ ] to
you that you did to your father like
that is really an interesting time like
I had this conversation with my son I
remember I had this and I called him
into my room one day I go hey man and he
goes what's up I said gee you know that
vodka doesn't freeze and he said I
didn't know that oh yeah did you know
that water does and he said I did know
that I go really then why is my vodka
frozen you dumbass like what why do I
have a popsicle in my freezer
look we all still booze from our parents
right we also boozed my parents but at
least I was creative about it I used to
put apple juice on the patio for two
weeks right so it would ferment so when
I put it back in my dad's bottle it
smelled like whiskey to this day my
dad's like man I can't drink that
whiskey it gives me the shits
so I told my son I was like doesn't man
I can't have you stealing things from
you want to know what something tastes
like you're old enough we can sit down
or whatever gonna taste it
and he was oh okay never happier before
and I said okay so I went out and I
bought us a case of beer and I was
sitting there I go look at this well
like gentlemen we're having a beer
together and and most important thing is
we're safe right buddy lesson number one
is you never drink and drive and then I
got him both teen shit-faced right he
would finish a beer I'm like shotgun
he's like what struck a girl right I
murdered him all right and he kept oh
and he passed out on the ground yeah so
so I shaved one of his eyebrows and then
I drew a dick on his cheek right here
cuz you never pass out first stupid
welcome the world daddy loves you just
trying to teach him one lesson to the
time my friends you know what I mean I'm
only one man I'm only one man